a local five-year-old is proving you're  never too young to make a difference  meet justin boma he's the youngest  non-profit founder  in las vegas with his heroes and hearts  organization isn't this wonderful  today he showed his appreciation to  local law enforcement by delivering gift  baskets full of treats  to officers at the bolden area command  why are you doing it why  why are you going all over the community  to help them to help them or should  to thank them it's great and i'm so  proud of him he has the heart of gold  and  i just i appreciate the city of las  vegas for helping my son's dream come  true  sweetest little boy well this was all  part of justin's three-part  project to celebrate and personally  express his gratitude to his local  firefighters  police officers postal workers and other  members of the community for their  perseverance  during this pandemic